So the democratic primary is taking very interesting
shape over the last 10 days.
The stories have big picture been Bernie climbing,
Bloomberg climbing, Biden falling with Bernie,
taking the lead and last week Michael Bloomberg
passing Pete boot edge edge and getting into
third place.
And as you know, I've been saying that despite
the very damaging audio and video of Michael
Bloomberg, which heavily publicizes lately
his horribly insensitive comments about stop
and frisk and race, I have been saying that
Bloomberg is going to end up doing way better
than anybody was thinking when he entered
this race.
And case in point breaking news, we have a
new poll with Michael Bloomberg and second
place qualifying qualifying for tomorrow's
debate in Nevada ahead of the Nevada caucuses.
The poll is an NPR PBS Marist poll of 1400
adults.
It has Bernie Sanders with an even bigger
lead than we've previously seen Bloomberg
in second place.
Let's look at the poll results.
Bernie at 31% a massive lead over Bloomberg
at 19% in second place, Biden in third at
15 Warren in fourth at 12 Klobuchar in fifth
with nine.
And in this poll, mayor Pete has fallen to
a sixth place with 8% of the vote, a complete
reversal from his recent momentum in Iowa
and New Hampshire.
Bernie in this poll since December, gaining
nine points.
Bloomberg gaining 15 since December, and the
biggest loser Biden going from 24 in this
same poll back in December, losing nine points
to 15.
So let's talk about the Bloomberg stuff a
little bit.
There's been a major online effort to attack
Michael Bloomberg as this racist oligarch
buying his way into the election, uh, which
is not a completely inaccurate framing, but
it may not be working.
I said early last week when our good friend
Ben Dickson publicized this horrible stop
and frisk audio that it may not have a significant
effect on Michael Bloomberg support.
And so far his support, at least in this poll,
has continued to increase.
Now, I don't believe Michael Bloomberg will
be the nominee, but he is going to be a factor
in determining who the nominee is, even if
it's merely by picking up just enough delegates
to prevent Bernie Sanders from getting the
nomination, which may be increasingly the
role for Michael Bloomberg as the democratic
establishment may see it.
But what is important in the immediate in
terms of how this changes the dynamic of the
race is that Michael Bloomberg has now qualified
for the debate in Nevada.
Just as we predicted, he would, based on the
rule changes from the DNC, which remove individual
donors as a fundraise, as a qualification
criteria, and now not only do you have Michael
Bloomberg spending what according to one report
is more than $300 million pouring it into
ads all over the place.
Internet, television, radio, I'm not sure
about, but possibly radio, you now will have
that money continuing to pour in and Michael
Bloomberg on the debate stage ahead of Nevada,
giving voters across the country their first
look at Bloomberg in a debate.
Now, if he doesn't do well in the debate,
this may be self-destructive.
If you believe that he will show up with at
least more energy than Biden and maybe getting
more speaking time than Warren and Buddha
judge.
Based on the recent polling, it's conceivable
that the combination of Bloomberg at the debate
and Bloomberg continuing to pour hundreds
of millions of dollars in is going to continue
giving him lift.
Meanwhile, the next primary is, as I mentioned,
the Nevada caucus.
It's on Saturday.
Very good news for Bernie Sanders there two
new polls this month, Bernie ahead and both
burning, leading by 19 in Nevada in the latest
DF, people a 35 to 16 over second place, Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie leading by seven in the
Las Vegas review journal poll 25 to 18 and
then lastly in our look at the polls in South
Carolina, Biden as of now, still in the lead,
Bernie and second, Tom Stier in third.
Stier needs some delegates there in order
to justify continuing past February 29th which
is when South Carolina will vote.
Otherwise, Tom Stier should likely exit before
super Tuesday.
So there are two movements that are getting
very agitated right now.
You have the establishment stop Bernie movement.
They are trying to figure out what's their
best bet.
It's clear that supporting Joe Biden was not
the right bet.
Biden now polling fourth, even fifth in some
places.
So do they move their support from Biden to
mayor Pete?
Do they consider Amy Klobuchar?
Do they abandon the sort of centrist establishment
Democrats all together and go to Bloomberg
who is a Republican for much of the last 20
years?
And meanwhile you have a stop Bloomberg movement
from those who have realized that Bloomberg's
massive polling gains may end up being what
prevents Bernie not from getting a plurality
of the delegates.
He still may, but what prevents Bernie from
getting 50% plus one which is what's required
to secure the nomination and prevent superdelegates
from getting to vote at the DNC right now,
the fivethirtyeight.com odds for the democratic
nomination are even money between Bernie securing
the nomination versus no one securing the
nomination and thus forcing a contested convention
two and five odds for both followed by a Biden
nomination as the next most likely scenario
at 12% the next 14 days will tell us probably
90% of what we need to know about this democratic
nomination process.
I believe that by super Tuesday, which is
two weeks from today, by the end of super
Tuesday, we will be able to say with 90% certainty
what the future of the democratic nomination
this
year is going to be